[Music]
in times have changed news submitted by
mall cops ha a study says the lack of
economically attractive men is to blame
for the decline in marriage what's
economically attractive men see they're
not making money mmm not economically
attractive right that's not making money
yeah yeah exactly so there is this new
study by Cornell University published in
the Journal of marriage and family by
the National Council on family relations
they said that US merit marriage rates
have reached a 150 year low and by the
way this study was conducted between
2012 and 2017 150 years is the lowest
right now that's why we shouldn't let
the gays marry I said that oh my god I
said I go ruin everything see all these
men all these men they're just marrying
each other they're just they're not
marrying women they're just I knew it as
soon as they're taking our job they're
making they're marrying cats and dogs
and my refrigerators and things gay
people love to marry refrigerators
that's what I heard that's what people
say out there yeah so researchers
analyzed opposite sex couples and he
compared the incomes of potential male
spouses with those of men who married
women of a similar demographic and they
found that men who haven't gotten
married earned 58 percent less than
those who did get married hmm that's
what how they're tying it to this and so
the state lessens a lot mm-hmm
you need a lot of money to have a family
though it makes sense if you're broke as
[ __ ] true you're not gonna want it no
one's gonna know this isn't even family
I think it's just marriage right well to
start up your attraction yeah I do one
just you
yeah if you don't even have money you're
not even a potential suitor to somewhere
yeah
Ward you got twins on the way dude
you're not gonna marry this chick you're
like [ __ ] I gotta wait I think [ __ ]
marriage was mentioned in this article
I'm like [ __ ] Steve man I agree with
you I think I think he's really jealous
that you have you started before heating
oh my god I think that's what's
happening we can't get pregnant cuz
we've been using birth control kidney
stones damn dude
well I lost my appendix last year's I'm
so sorry how did that happen it I did
just [ __ ] hurt a lot on my rights
they just hurt I thought I thought I
just needed to take a [ __ ] oh man I
remember calling my mom like mom like it
like this [ __ ] isn't coming tell her mom
Rama mom oh yeah I caught a mama grandma
okay and um but yeah when he got some
blood work done and they were just like
dude you got a ticket out oh [ __ ] you
have to do surgery you is blood work
yeah yeah wait with blood work and then
they did like but no one knows why cat
scan it was just like it was like no one
knew I like they're just like yeah I got
to get out probably do have an SD card
do you caught do you call El Torito or
Alto 800 restaurant that's not my
favorite restaurant that was your
favorite or do you sillies Chili's
oh you think Chili's the dog no any less
than one I can talk I got all wrong
well the hell their baby back rib is
teyla now actually one of my first boss
called Sobolev in paramount if you guys
ever go saw my last is alright
the best tequila there is it really bro
what kind of team up J got thicker gasp
ah Doris oh I like that that's the best
their top shots the Mexican thank you is
there a warm Montano it's one no words
oh it's warm and warlocks inside
everywhere
alright got some letters in it no at all
not that one mezcal God yeah you guys
are drinking buddies oh yeah hey what's
going on with broke guys they can't get
they can't get married you should go to
the factory
good for you have fun I think are they
still getting laid okay Oh probably I
don't know this is not good so they get
all the benefits without all the
troubles sixty seventy two percent of
adults in the US were married no there
are more adults adult couples that are
living together than before but there
are only 50 percent married yeah we got
smarter that's why yeah the same [ __ ]
mistakes I hear that's true cuz cuz
smarter people have less kids that's
that's the studies yeah but the tax
deductible is really great though when
you're married true I mean I wouldn't
know but I've heard yeah yeah roast
yourself before he [ __ ] gets you
there you go think about all the money
you're spending on [ __ ] though
for those kids just paying sales tax
well that [ __ ] it's not it's a wash have
you have you bought this [ __ ] it's not
that expensive scusi have you bought it
like it's not that expensive up paying
for two kids yeah but when you win you
every kid you
that's crazy can't get my head around it
it shouldn't as much as two cats no it's
not you know it's not the [ __ ] vet
bill is [ __ ] insane yeah bill yeah I
had to take my sister's a vet first of
all obviously that's cool I have [ __ ]
you drive all but Huizar
two hours out excuse me you drive two
hours out I would have been pretty
healthy thankfully Eric's bag
diapers food mini vans and [ __ ] are you
getting a mini man you got drug video
all the Mexicans I know I think I did
yeah I'll chappals up all in Mexico yeah
yeah isn't the most richest man in the
world a Mexican yeah it's a cat Carlos
wim Lebanese all right he's not the
richest but he's he's top five it's a
guy with like like a mobile phone
there's something out in Mexico tell us
something you guys really know your
culture was just Christ I'm not only got
[ __ ] noses [ __ ] and they're not even
paid it's fine Carlos Slim I knew his
name it's mine no nobody here you
actually care about who is yeah he
already said it we moved it once I
forgot yeah he's the owner Slim Jim
anyway back to these statistics for
marriage yeah so they're saying that the
dream husband's were also 30% more
likely to be employed and 19 percent
more likely to have a college degree and
they're saying 30% if you must have a
bachelor's degree or a stable job making
at least 40,000 a year I mean that's a
that's just the bare bones kind of thing
to do right well that's what they're
saying
Yeah right like the 58% so there's just
a lot of dudes that aren't employed and
don't have college degrees
and that's why the I mean
the studies saying that because of that
reason there are fewer marriages
happening so now there's just more guys
not getting educated and getting better
jobs is that what it is maybe you could
boil it down to that yeah if you're
hurtin eats hmm
meets must have an eat not in education
employment or training and that's like a
whole thing we're gonna talk about the
peeling oh no no that's a straight
losses a bomb is not having ice with
your drink I know that please a bump but
yeah not educated in ramallah education
or training employment so what are you
doing sitting home jacking off all day
that's what they should call it but yeah
it's a whole thing yes because college
is expensive as [ __ ] and then a lot of
people have had problems holding work
down because they have weird habits and
[ __ ] and so yeah jacking off at work
right or whatever do you think
cuz you know how today we have so many
different avenues of making money maybe
those aren't considered being employed
that's a good point
no no I really depends on how the how
they call they classify it cuz if it's
just like only w-2s or like W fours and
they don't want to classify - I think
more women pursue higher education now
than men statistically you think so
today stay in school longer they don't
drop out hmm so and they just work
better in that area yeah I don't know
guys are [ __ ] nut though yeah dude
there's a lot that's going on out there
I think liquid between like a lot of
people addicted to different substances
and [ __ ] and nobody's really gettin help
or talking about it much and so I think
there's a lot of that going on that's
underlying a lot of this [ __ ]
so you think talking about it would help
people get sure I mean my grandpa was an
alcoholic and never talked about it
mostly cuz he was drunk a job though
true but right but he then he retired
and then he was just like drinking some
more time dude but he's retired so he
paid us to do whatever you might
yeah so guys now are even paying their
dues yeah exactly just staying home and
jacking off all day yeah britty much
yeah do you need to be what often writes
what they do think he's right yeah you
don't know how how boys are they just
sit home and jack off all day would they
would if I had a dick I'd probably do
that too
yeah it's fun man when you being a girl
huh there's more fun just gonna be
tagging out but whatever as a girl I'd
like to it's a masturbate chillin office
yeah so we get more pleasure and like
higher pleasure than guys do but we
don't even do that oh that's true cuz
you can suck your own teddy and stuff
[Laughter]
teenee wall a master be up think of this
you count the karlon balls or Regina
though of course I wait took yoga I
would I'd suck my own dick for I could
reach it yeah I think I'd be really good
maybe I'm not above all type of dude
either you know you are you brought it
up
no I brought it up because someone
recently was talking to me about like
hey have you ever had your girl like eat
your ass oh it's amazing
no no I don't know this world deep some
bones damn know that he had his ass
eaten a lot cuz when you look at his ex
she's always like looking at the floor
and looking a little bummed out ex you
haven't seen a wonderful breakup video
haha yes
i drained the swamp out of this [ __ ]
top that's right I'm making it work and
on top of that we did off-the-record hon
just kidding news if you guys haven't
seen it check that we tell all working
like claymation one two yeah we're about
fired and I word in that video so we're
about to film our own yeah yeah we'll
put it on your place you wouldn't
believe the things that Joanne just told
us that's right Oh finally revealed the
finally revealed finally finally the
actual truth thumbnails gonna be like
beautiful sigh hug me I'm good that's
good [ __ ] yeah that's really good [ __ ]
[Music]